you've got so many fans of course online  and they're always doing these weird  things we found this one thing that's  been getting some traction someone  photoshopped a picture of you that they  morphed they took your face and they  morphed it onto Steve Buscemi's yes a  head I don't know why but look at it I  [Applause]  love Steve Buscemi I'm a huge it he's a  great guy and assemble him at all no I  don't know what someone thinks things  but they they do it and then of course  you see it you go I don't know why would  that is oddly compelling no it's crazy  it actually resembles my father is that  true yeah dad looks like  not quite my dad's maybe a little bit  better looking yeah yeah it's your dad  what form that's your dad yeah yeah it's  your that's  [Applause]  you